foreign
s Us in Chesapeake Virginia coming up
next Henry what's going on
hey Ramsey team thank you for taking my
call absolutely what's going on
so I recently completed your foundations
in personal finance homeschool
curriculum and I have a question about
Investments okay hit me how old are you
so I'm 16. don't hit George it's a whole
thing I'll go down easy yeah
all right so
specifically my question is Pokemon
cards
cards Pokemon cards don't have any value
in them and that they won't make me any
money but it seems like every Pokemon
card set from previous years has just
been going up and up in price
for example a box of Pokemon cards that
were released in 2021 originally sold
for 120 now they sell for about 400.
what are your thoughts and our Pokemon
cards good or not good Investments
great question very well worded Henry
and I'm proud of you for going through
the curriculum did you learn anything in
the curriculum about investing do you
remember anything from that section I
learned that I should never invest in
anything that I do not know about that's
good you seem to know a lot about
Pokemon cards that's for sure
will you teach me something about
Pokemon that I don't know and this will
be even that was a challenge because
John knows everything
I have I
I don't know what Pokemon is so tell me
well
originally released
at mid 90s 90 in Japan and its original
name is Pocket Monsters And it used to
be where it first used to be a game on
the Game Boy Called Pokemon Red and Blue
you're like a Pokemon scholar
this is amazing
so and eventually it kind of evolved
into Pokemon cards which came out in
Japan about 1997 and in America about
1999.
this is what I grew up playing John was
Game Boy Pokemon got the cards from my
friends and you got the packs for you
know four or five bucks
did you though I'm just I don't know
sure
okay all right so George is going to
teach us so the thing Henry is
there's a lot of Collectibles out there
and people can make money and you
probably have seen YouTubers like Logan
Paul who are like I paid five million
dollars for this super rare charge right
that's the stuff that we see that we
click on that we view the reality is
most people it's like going to Vegas
it's like the slot machine you're hoping
that you get the pack with the right
card and all of a sudden you went I
spent 300 bucks and my cars aren't worth
nothing
and so the chances of you getting that
card that you can then flip and make a
whole bunch of money isn't worth the
time now if you wanted to do this beyond
your normal Investments with just your
fun money and you're super into it you
could do it
and I bet you would call back and you'd
be like hey I have seven million dollars
because I invested in Pokemon cards and
we'd all be like what this kid's crazy
and so I'm not saying that it can't be
done I don't want to shoot down your
dreams but the truth is these
Collectibles these Commodities they're
just based on hype and so pokemania
could end next year all of a sudden
because we all move on to something else
versus something like the stock market
Which history has shown us will
appreciate over time yes there'll be
some volatility but over 50 years it's
going to be a good investment we just
don't know that about Pokemon cards
now here's my challenge to your parents
I think they're right I think George is
right
they're not great investment vehicles
and also
sometimes having a collectible that
you're interested in is fun and you
clearly have a lot of it you know the
history of Pokemon cards so is is
trading cards getting new cards going
through the value of them is that fun
for you is that exciting
well it's exciting to open Pokemon card
packs and see that these are pretty rare
from the sets that they were released
and going well this is like one of the
rarest cards in the set
yeah so I
I don't want you to lose that joy for
something that you're interested in that
you think is fun
I just don't want you to go into debt
for it and I want you to not save up for
college for it
but man I want you to enjoy your life
too
all right and something's so it's about
the spirit of it right George yeah
there's an entrepreneurial spirit that
you have Henry where you go I love
something but I also want to see like
could I make money from this and that's
a great thing to feel inside you just
want to do it the right way otherwise
you're going to be chasing the next kind
of get rich quick thing I'm gonna buy
this and hope because it's the same
spirit that a lot of the crypto Bros
have right you know about cryptocurrency
and they're going oh if we just get this
one coin it's gonna be worth 10x a year
from now this is going to be the one and
so you're kind of hoping for the same
thing with Pokemon cards that if I just
buy the right pack it's going to have
the right collectible that one day will
be worth something so I would do it
because you love it and do it with your
extra fun money but I would not do it as
part of your investing strategy and
George let me I'm gonna ask you about
this or tell you about this I
this is 10 12 years ago I had just
bought a house and then somebody else
bought a house down the street and I was
checking every house purchase to see
what they were buying theirs for and I
was kind of doing my own comps in my
house because I was a little bit
and I was trying to keep up with every
sale and what are you listing it for and
I was talking to a finance buddy and he
said something that was important for me
he said because I was telling him hey I
think I'm gonna sell now because it's
gone up this much in three months I'm
gonna do this he said hey and here's the
line he gave me he said give your wife a
home
he said you're gonna make money on your
house over time probably maybe not but
probably
but man if you Roi every single
transaction in your life you're gonna
make yourself nuts and it was a call
back to have a place where you can drop
your shoulders like a home right
follow good money principles obviously
but we can get obsessed about things and
so I used to buy a guitar and then I
would always like how much does it cost
how much does it cost and have I made
any money now I buy a guitar because I
like it and I want to play it and I have
a scenario in my head where I'm going to
play it live and if one day it's worth
money great but I had the money now I
saved up the money I bought it I like it
I play it
and if it loses money I still got the
enjoyment out of it that I wanted right
and so I think with things like Pokemon
cards with some baseball cards whatever
thing you're kind of into
have a spirit of Joy about it and if it
goes down in value you still got you
still have the joy but man there's just
I think there's a few things I think we
over Roi everything in our culture and
we over hack everything and there's some
things like home there's some things
like strumming a guitar in your basement
when your kids are asleep there's
something about I don't know writing in
your favorite Journal that are things
that just bring you peace and they bring
you Joy and they bring you beauty to
your life
man those those are worth the
expenditure in and of themselves and if
they end up being worth money on the
road great right yeah you make a great
Point there's a lot of things in our
lives that we
subconsciously make Idols in our lives
where we spend so much time in it around
it that it takes over our brain and so
when when crypto came about my major
issue with crypto was not that you're
going to lose a bunch of money that's a
possibility my issue with crypto was
that it was 24 7 and you can just see on
your app at volatility all day long and
it was so many it was new coins there
was Community groups all about it and
you could just have it consume your life
and that's why I joked that crypto is
just you know Mary Kay for young men
because there was this obsessive nature
just like there is with multi of
multi-level marketing where people were
just it took over their life it became a
personality trait and that's where I go
let's draw a line here it's great to
enjoy something it's not great to be
consumed by it that turns into an
addiction I love that that's good there
are some wisdom for you John but I don't
wanna I don't want to hurt Henry's
dreams because I this kid's amazing he's
going to go big places and there's
nothing wrong with using these Pokemon
cards and having fun with it well and I
I also think that's an important
conversation to have with parents um
so my son uh he cleans out the horse
stalls of the the people who live next
to us on on the ranch next to us
and he earns his own money and he also
mows our yard and I pay him
um for helping participate in in mowing
our place and he earns his own money and
then he'll want to spend it on something
and my first impulse is off often that's
stupid or why would you want to spend it
and then I think no he's 13. this is
when he's going to learn those lessons
of value and what's important and what's
not important so we're taking care of
the giving we're taking care of the
saving
it's your money right and I think for
parents it's good to teach them lessons
but also let him learn oh I spent 25 on
what right and man that wasn't worth it
yeah and learning that way is much
healthier than being forced to never get
to play a video game your whole life or
Never Getting to buy some Pokemon cards
so I'm rooting for you Henry keep us
posted on how it goes my friend